un petit mot à une énorme signification
dans la version j'en avais un site ces
bandes de racailles
et emmanuelli globe on a plus en plus de
petites phrases dans débat public
le bruit et l'odeur je pense pas que ce
soit volontaire le fait qu'ils sortent
des petits trucs comme ça
quoique
on a l'air en eau de la république
actuellement il y a dans cette société
une majorité de femmes il y en a qui
sont pour beaucoup
ils les traits après le scandale des
temps dans quoi tu es maintenant de lui
délivrer ces jo longeant c'est
extrêmement violent attention à ce
nouveau langage
[Musique]
françois hollande
emmanuel macron deux ambitieux issu de
l'élite de la nation deux présidents
porté au pouvoir par la gauche pour l'un
et par l'espoir d'un renouveau pour
l'eau si le protéger a trahi son mentor
tous deux ont en commun d'avoir été pris
en défaut par leurs petites phrases
accusé de mépris envers les plus pauvres
il y a dans cette société majorité de
femmes il y en a qui sont pour beaucoup
ils les traits il est trés sens dans des
mots prononcés en public ou en privé
assumer ou non mais qui ont mis au jour
lors décalage avec le peuple jusqu'à
provoquer la colère de la rue
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on dit on
descend dans la rue on est le slogan de
la république actuellement c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait
2014 c'est l'année de tous les extrêmes
le climat s'affolent les 1014 année la
plus chaude depuis un siècle
les milliardaires e hamas les 300
personnalités les plus riches de la
planète ont gagné en 2013
381 milliards d'euros en 2014
les français découvrent les infidélités
de leur président et ses escapades en
scooter à la une de la presse à scandale
et un ministre thomas thévenoud
découvreurs d'une nouvelle maladie la
phobie administrative la république
exemplaire c'est quoi thomas thévenoud
n'est pas en règle avec le fisc
un petit tour et puis s'en va
en 2014 le front national remporté les
européennes
la première victoire du parti à une
élection nationale le ps divisé comme
jamais s'effondre aux municipales août
après trois mois seulement le nouveau
gouvernement formé par manuel valls se
prend l'eau tout est dans le symbole
pour sa fête de la rose arnaud
montebourg a choisi une cuvée celle du
redressement qu'il adresse au président
je vais lui envoyer une bonne bouteille
de la cuvée du redressement président
trois ministres parmi les plus à gauche
quitte le navire
en désaccord avec la politique
économique de françois hollande c'est le
jour on né le 25 août 2014 où il vient à
l'île de sein 25 août normalement il n'y
a pas de tempête à l'île de sein sauf
qu'il ya une tempête épouvantable et
puis une pluie épouvantable
le message de l'île de sein c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de péril pas de difficulté que
nous puissions surmonter dès lors que la
volonté existe c'est le moment où ils
partent montebourg hamon et philippe
éthique et perdre trois ministres d'un
couple
sale temps pour le président une petite
tempête qui en annonce une grande elle
arrive quelques jours plus tard à la
surprise générale c'est un livre de 320
pages écrit dans le plus grand secret
c'est une nouvelle étape qui vient
d'être franchie dans la confusion entre
vie privée et vie publique
jamais une ex première dame ne s'était
laissé aller à de telles confidences je
fais déjà c'est une top peut dire ça
comme ça c'est très mauvais livres bâle
visera le mythe et c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant c'est un livre qui s'est
vendu très largement
mais les français aiment bien lire des
livres
quand ils peuvent regarder par le trou
de la serrure
c'est un livre trou de la serrure je
dois dire que j'ai un petit peu honte un
sentiment de voyeurisme mais que
j'assume c'est quelqu'un qui je suis
désolé de dire ça parce que ça ça
m'embête toujours de parler des
sentiments des autres mais qui se venge
quand même d'une situation personnelle
en disant ce président est inconstant et
c'est moi je les lui en entier il ya des
pages qui sont agréables bien sûr mais
on voit bien qu'à certains moments
certaines pages
il est fait pour nuire il est fait pour
blesser le françois hollande ce bouquin
n'a pas fait de bien n'a pas fait de
bien
il a atteint son objectif
merci pour ce moment un brûlot vendu à
plus de 750 mille exemplaires qui décrit
sans pudeur neuf ans de la vie du couple
jusqu'à leur séparation en janvier 2014
trois cents pages de règlements de
comptes privés dont une petite phrase va
avoir d'énormes conséquences publiques
en réalité le président n'aime pas les
pauvres lui l'homme de gauche dit en
privé les sens dans très fier de son
trait d'humour
la seule chose qui était pour lui est la
plus grave dans le livre c'était qu'elle
était qu'elle accusait de traiter les
pauvres de son gant c'est ça était le
plus lourd pour lui la phrase sur les
sens d'en bas elle m'a surprise parce
que je connais françois hollande pas été
d'accord avec les options qu'il a pu
prendre en particulier la fin de son
mandat et sur ce que j'appelle la
tentation néolibérale mai
je connais l'homme est son empathie
globale à l'égard des gens même si
certains disent qu'il n'est ni bon ni
ronny généreux je crois qui il a
vraiment envie que les gens aillent
mieux c'est pour faire court ça ne se
fait pas en public c'est dans un
contexte privatif
c'est une formule qui est censé ramasser
toute une série de traits qui
caractérisent celles et ceux qui sont
véritablement en bas de l'échelle
sociale et dont la condition sociale se
lit pas simplement dans leur bulletin de
salaire mais sur leur corps
l'expression sans dans la la force d
expression figurative
c'est à dire qu'elle donne à voir elle
énonce un thème la pauvreté non pas avec
un concept comme la misère par exemple
mais à travers une image et cette image
elle résonne profondément dans la
mémoire figurative des français je crois
que ça envoie un message de
stigmatisation les classes populaires ne
s'attendent pas surtout celles qui sont
tout en bas de l'échelle sociale ne
s'attendent pas être qualifié de sang
d'angle c'est une image d'elle-même qui
lorsqu'elle est une réalité c'est une
image d'elle-même qui préfèrent oublier
c'est les gens d'en haut qui parle aux
gens d'en bas
en assistant sur un attribut que les
gens d'en haut ont toutes leur dentition
et que les gens d'en bas
non hélas plus tout leur dentition
l'expression qui a été prêté à françois
hollande par son ex-compagne
effectivement avait fait la une de la
presse et bien évidemment en tant que
dentiste attention avait été aussitôt
attiré puisque l'expression est assez
dur si vous voulez et injuste c'est
injuste de traiter quelqu'un de sang
dans cinna pas de danse et pas du tout
de sa faute tout ça peut ne pas être du
tout sa faute c'est vraiment une
question de manque de moyens financiers
laissant dans ou comment un moment
volets de la vie privée de françois
hollande va le toucher en tant qu'homme
et anéantir toute une vie d'engagement
politique
françois hollande est un président
socialiste de gauche ce qui a peu touché
en fait la vie l'engagement politique de
françois hollande et à travers lui la
gauche et social c'est uniquement cette
expression un homme de gauche qui
méprise les pauvres plus et c'est la
contradiction idéologique maximale quoi
ces mêmes meuse qui est il dit
d'ailleurs c'est l'expression du cynisme
moi je n'ai jamais entendu françois
hollande parler comme ça hollande n'a
jamais eu de mépris à l'égard des gens
de la pauvreté jamais qui vivent la
pauvreté ni jamais
face à la déferlante médiatique le
président est contraint de réagir
publiquement
habituellement jovial et blagueur il a
perdu son sourire
fait exceptionnel il le fait lors d'un
sommet international devant la presse du
monde entier
signe de la gravité de la situation
aujourd'hui seul président le livre de
l'ex première dame connais ta
retentissement considérable
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que au
delà de ce que vous pouvez ressentir son
plan personnel que certaines révélations
dégrade de façon irrémédiable votre
crédibilité et la fonction
présidentielle
je n'accepterai jamais je dis bien
jamais que puisse être mise en cause ce
qui est l'engagement de toute ma vie je
ne vais pas laisser mettre en cause la
conception de mon action au service des
français et notamment de la relation
humaine que j'ai avec les plus fragiles
parce que je suis à leurs services
et parce que c'est ma raison d'être tout
simplement ma raison d'être
on attend le retour de françois hollande
qui revient de cardiff et s'adresse à
nous et avait de la pudeur de françois
hollande qui n'aime pas du tout parlé de
la de sa vie privée et il nous dit je
n'ai pas le droit de communiquer mes
sentiments
mon devoir est quoi qu'il m'arrive à moi
françois hollande est de préserver la
fonction présidentielle
je le connais depuis 35 ans ilan sacré
solidité intérieur il prendra il prendra
commander tout sur lui quelques jours
après françois hollande brise un peu
l'armure dans une unique interview au
nouvel observateur il se dit blessé
valérie trierweiler peut avoir écrit
beaucoup de choses sur leur vie intime
et lui prêter à lui françois hollande
l'expression laissant dans pour parler
des pauvres c'est apparemment beaucoup
trop et livre sa version descendants oui
j'ai rencontré des gens dans les pires
difficultés usé par la vie
il avait du mal à soigner leurs dents
c'est le signe de la pire misère ces
gens je les ai côtoyés aidé et soutenu
ils essaient de recontextualiser
l'expression pour lui retirer cette
généralisation qui serait là la
définition des pauvres
ça n'est pas une généralisation de la
pauvreté en général autrement dit mais
la connotation si on peut dire de de
l'expression dans le contexte de
françois hollande c'est une connotation
compassionnel alors que changer de
contexte ça devient une connotation
méprisante dans le livre valérie très
yves heller évidemment tort un peu les
choses et considère qu'il est méprisant
et qui qualifie les pauvres de 100 dans
françois hollande peine à se défendre si
les mots ont été prononcés en privé
l'expression dans sa bouche et crédible
lui le blagueur
l'auteur de bons mots payerez t-il cette
propension à l'humour dont il est
coutumier
écoutez moi j'étais dans le même lycée
que clavier jugnot donc j'ai gardé et
finalement une fidélité à ce comité là
je suis café-théâtre si vous voulez je
ne peux pas comme président de la
république supprimer la pluie je ne peux
pas non plus la provoquer même si
certains ont imaginé cette hypothèse je
le redis pour se débarrasser de nicolas
sarkozy vous connaissez la nouvelle du
jour
le président candidat est désormais
candidat président il manie l'humour à
ça ça il est plutôt cinglant il peut
même être d'ailleurs cruel avec l'humour
il peut lui-même blessé en utilisant son
humour on peut aller très loin dans
l'humour français
c'est pour ça qu'on chope beaucoup les
anglo saxons dont l'impression que le
mot français toujours iconoclaste qui
quitte ea qui transgresse les frontières
mais pour un homme de gauche même si on
le fait au travers de l'humour faut pas
transgresser certains tabous quoi il ya
d'autres manières de les qualifier comme
utilisant ce terme de s'entendre
d'ailleurs il est très frappant de
constater que pendant sa mandature
françois hollande à limiter
considérablement sa propension au mot
d'esprit et à l'humour parce que le
propre d'un mot d'esprit c'est d'être
ambiguë et c'est justement le jeu sur
une ambiguïté qui permet de jouer sur le
contexte et si on change le contexte il
peut devenir catastrophique
c'est drôle de l'ironie la fameuse
histoire de de montesquieu sur les
esclaves
si j'avais à défendre les esclaves voici
ce que je dirais ils ont un gros nez ils
ont des grosses révisions sujet c'est
complètement ironique mais ça a été
interprété jusqu'au xxème siècle
d'ailleurs comme nom ironique parce que
c'était décontextualisés
le contexte de cette petite phrase va
connaître un nouvel éclairage quelques
années plus tard en 2016 françois
hollande se confie longuement à deux
journalistes dans un livre et revient
sur l'expression descendants qu'il admet
avoir pu utiliser en privé mais sans
mépris réponse immédiate de son
ex-compagne sur twitter qui persiste et
signe
valérie trierweiler publié un sms vieux
de plus de 8 ans attribuée à françois
hollande je suis avec ma copine
bernadette dans une grande manifestation
dans son canton
je lui ai fait un numéro de charme mais
tu ne dois pas t'inquiéter dans son
discours elle a fait un lapsus
formidable rire général même chez les
sens dans cette histoire remarquable
parce qu'elles changent leur registre
c'est à dire qu'ici ce que l'on voit
c'est que la bernadette en question
c'est bernadette chirac
les faits remontent au 31 mai 2008 le
président du conseil général de corrèze
françois hollande et la conseillère
générale du canton de sarre en
bernadette chirac inauguré ensemble ce
jour-là un centre culturel dans leur
département c'est ce registre de la
dérision de ce fameux trait d'humour
caractéristiques de la personnalité du
discours de françois hollande d'une
manière plus générale qui fait qu'on
peut se dire ce matin pas de la chose
que c'est un petit mot qu'ils ont entre
eux une sorte de petite plaisanterie si
on est attentif le contexte du discours
montre que c'est un mot d'esprit partagé
que elle même doit l'utiliser
en déballant un échange privé valérie
trierweiler ce piège et nous apprend que
l'expression attribuée à françois
hollande serait parti de corrèze les
attentes et on va plus les voir si vous
voulez dans les milieux défavorisés
soyons clairs on va plus et voir au
niveau de la pl france profonde
et là vous verrez en regardant bien les
gens et surtout quand vous avez un oeil
de dentiste à nos yeux
exercez vous verrez assez facilement des
gens qui ont des dents - des tentes
devant mais derrière et qui ne le seront
pas remplacés sont des gens qui auraient
peut-être les moyens de se faire
remplacer leurs dents mais qu'il n'y
attachent à une importance folle si leur
manque une banque 2 ça ne gêne pas pour
vivre et eux ça ne les gêne pas dans les
contacts sociaux
quoi qu'il en soit c'est bien françois
hollande qui payent des sa révélation un
lourd prix politique pour une formule
privé qui n'avait pas vocation à devenir
publique et l'arrivée au plus mauvais
moment parce que ça y est le président
perd la main et où sans peut-être que
françois hollande va vers un destin qui
sera celui du premier président sortant
qui ne peut pas se représenter
mais c'est comme ça que ça se finira
c'est une phrase qui a été re dit par
volonté de nuire donc mise en scène dans
le bouquin est mise en scène pour
qu'elles atterrissent effectivement sur
des banderoles
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on dit on
descend dans la rue on est les sonos de
la république actuellement c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait de nous l'expression
était politiquement intéressant
les manifestants se sont pas trompés ils
ont ils ont eu exactement la même
analyse et ils ont j'en en profiter si
je puis dire pour l'attaqué l'accusé à
partir de cette expression en écrivant
je pense qu'elle savait ce qu'elle
faisait
parce que l'auteur du livre est aussi
journaliste c'est la manière dont un
petit mot à une énorme signification
c'est dire que je prends l'image soul et
du mot comme une sorte de cache et
effervescents et vous le mettez dans
l'eau théorêt contexte est tout d'un
coup ça foisonne et l'histoire
descendants est typique de cette espèce
d'expansion considérable du sens autour
de l'expression elle-même c'est-à-dire
l'interprétation politique des actions
jugées libérales par la gauche à gauche
de françois hollande
mené dans la conduite des affaires et
cette interprétation là vient donner un
sens au sens dans comme une sorte d'aveu
idéologique d'aveux qu' il n'est plus de
gauche
si des leaders de gauche mettent à
parler comme ça c'est peut-être pas par
hasard c'est que depuis des décennies la
gauche française a peu à peu perdu son
électorat populaire qui est parti vers
d'autres horizons et l'électorat de la
gauche est devenue un électorat de
couches moyennes de cols blancs et de
bourgeois
mais il ya peut-être aussi un
embourgeoisement de leur attitude
une forme de mépris de classe qui
paradoxalement s'exprime chez des gens
qui véritablement nous avait pas habitué
à cela l'expression fait d'autant plus
mal que le françois hollande candidat de
2012 a été élu sur un programme très à
gauche
dans la campagne de françois hollande
il a fait le discours fondateur le 22
janvier 2012 au blond j'ai un candidat
capable d'être président il a toujours
un discours fondateur incarner le
changement
faire gagner la gauche alors il sait en
effet que contre nicolas sarkozy qui est
accusée à tort ou à raison de néo
libéralisme échevelé
il ya un créneau c'est le créneau en
effet traditionnels de la gauche
française qui consiste à dire qu'avec la
gauche ou en finira avec ce nouveau
visage du capitalisme qu'est le
capitalisme financier sans frontières
apatride créateur de crise
dans cette bataille qui s'engage je vais
vous dire qui est mon adversaire
mon véritable adversaire il n'a pas de
nom pas de visage pas de partis
il le présentera jamais sa candidature
il ne sera donc pas élu et pourtant ils
gouvernent cet adversaire c'est le monde
de la finance
c'est ça qui était retenu mais c'est une
phrase susceptibles de lui être
reprochées en permanence parce que c'est
jamais assez quand vous êtes dans
l'opposition y compris internes au parti
socialiste
vous pouvez vous en donner à coeur joie
on verra ce qui restera quelques mois
plus tard de ce message
mon ennemi c'est la finance mais deux
ans après son élection en 2014
ces sympathisants déchantent moins d'un
sur deux lui fais confiance
[Musique]
moi c'est une année je fais campagne des
municipales
donc je rencontre des tas de personnes
et c'est une année où me revient non pas
en moment mais j'irai en mangent leurs
atours ces expressions pas de désespoir
mais vous n'étiez pas au rendez vous
vous n'avez pas été au rendez vous on
est déçu on est mal
on attendait beaucoup en termes de lutte
contre les inégalités la fameuse phrase
mon ennemi c'est la finance on attendait
beaucoup gênés en termes simplement de
de justice et on a eu peu
malheureusement françois hollande est
peut-être manuel valls ne l'ont pas
entendu la famille socialiste est
déboussolé mais françois hollande en
2014 assume son virage politique jusque
là il se disait socialiste
hier il avait franchi le pas
suis-je un social-démocrate oui au sens
où ce pacte de responsabilité qu'est ce
que c'est d'autre qu'une démarche de
compromis social donc social-démocrate
ça à troubler l'électorat socialiste
c'est surtout le lectorat centrale en
fait qu'est le plus important qui se
dégradent et puis ça s'accélère a par la
suite à force de vouloir ménager la
chèvre et le chou c'est à la fois le
libéralisme et et la social démocratie
ils n'arrivent plus à rien sinon à
mettre quelques pansements sur une jambe
de moi ce que je fais et corrige un
système elles ne le font pas bouger et
nous un certain nombre avec martine
aubry avec beaucoup d'autres y compris
jean marc ayrault on ne réussit pas à
faire passer le message que la tentation
de néo libérale n'est plus
une vue de l'esprit ou un écrit
d'économistes atterrés mais une réalité
après les révélations sur les 100 dans
la rupture avec le peuple se creuse près
de trois quart de l'électorat de gauche
ne veut plus de françois hollande comme
président la ferté veut nous laissant
dans le virage social libéral les
raisons du désamour ne manquent pas une
dégringolade qui va profiter à l'un de
ces jeunes conseillers emmanuel macron
il ne manie pas l'humour comme son
mentor mais va lui aussi se laisser
piéger par ses petites phrases il y a
dans cette société majorité de femmes il
y en a qui sont pour beaucoup
il est trés après le scandale des
onguents voici maintenant celui des
illettrés des petites phrases lourdes de
conséquences monsieur emmanuel macron
ministre de l'économie de l'industrie et
numérique
il revient par la grande porte lui qui
avait quitté son poste de secrétaire
général adjoint de l'elysée début
juillet c'est ainsi pour la première
fois ce matin à la table du conseil des
ministres fin août 2014
le destin des manuels macron se joue
peut-être sur une démission
je dirais qu'il faut savoir quitter la
scène quand on ne sait pas jouer plus
longtemps la comédie à 36 ans le protégé
de françois hollande remplace le
frondeur et trop à gauche arnaud
montebourg au ministère de l'économie
un profil plus jeune plus fidèles plus
libérale aussi
il était le contraire de monter morin
n'a pas franchement le grand contraire
de mon topo bonne chance manu et vive le
redressement productif de l'économie
française vive la république et vive la
france
[Applaudissements]
emmanuel macron c'est l'homme qui depuis
2012 murmure ses conseils à l'oreille de
françois hollande à l'elysée
a bercy il a pour collègues marylise
lebranchu élue bretonne et socialiste
pur jus emmanuel macron est quelqu'un
qui est aux manettes quand il est
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
feraient jamais l'oublier dire que quand
il passe au gouvernement il passe d'un
poste de pouvoir silencieux un poste de
pouvoir effectif elle est dans nos mains
pour le choix des manuels macron est
forcément un tournant la perception
qu'ont les politiques de l'entreprise
à ce moment-là a profondément changé en
tout cas dans le logiciel socialiste ça
c'est très clair on revient à la réalité
la création de richesse elle se fait par
les entreprises elle se fait pas par
hasard en passant de l'ombre à la
lumière
emmanuel macron impose son style en
décalage complet avec celui de son
mentor sûr de lui à l'elysée mais aussi
auparavant à la banque rothschild où il
a fait fortune
bardé de diplômes emmanuel macron n'a
jamais caché son ambition
j'arrive tout auréolé d'une réputation
qui m'est faite par la presse je dois le
dire et jugez moi sur les actes et sur
les paroles le voeu des manuels macron
va très vite être exaucé car côté
paroles il sort l'artillerie lourde
comme ministre puis comme candidat et
une fois élu président de la république
il va faire un usage massif et délibérée
de la petite phrase et la vie d'un
entrepreneur
elle est bien souvent plus dure que
celle d'un salarié faut jamais l'oublier
parce qu'il peut tout perdre lui là-haut
françois hollande a toujours mesurer ses
propos en public
lui assume sa méthode le parler vrai il
ya des choses qui marchent pas il faut
les dénoncer et je ne céderai rien
bonjour à coup de petites phrases
il dresse le portrait d'une certaine
france un pays de gaulois réfractaires
ou les jeunes devrait avoir comme
ambition de devenir milliardaire plutôt
qu'être enclin la feignantise
même franc-parler maladroit et
dévastateur de vente et militante était
il ya tout un de vérité d'emmanuel mâcon
qui se dit dans cette phrase je vais
être honnête avec vous je n'y crois pas
c'est pour ça que je fais ce que je fais
je pense pas que ce soit volontaire fait
qu'ils sortent des petits trucs comme ça
quoique avec sa méthode
emmanuel macron dérange bouscule
transgresse lui analyse les problèmes
avec froideur et ne vaut pas l'effet
dévastateur que peut avoir son parler
vrai une déconnexion totale résumé par
la sphère des illettrés une petite
phrase lâchée à l'occasion de sa
première interview comme ministre à
propos de sa réforme du permis de
conduire
le ministre évoque la nécessité de
petites réformes
il se met alors à parler du prix du
permis de conduire et prend l'exemple
des abattoirs breton gad écouter le
permis de conduire aujourd'hui dans ce
pays et coûte en moyenne 1500 euros il
faut attendre plusieurs mois parfois
plusieurs années avant de pouvoir le
passer dans les sociétés qui me sont
données sur les dossiers que j'ai et la
société gad
vous savez cet abattoir il y a dans
cette société une majorité de femmes
il y en a qui sont pour beaucoup ils les
traits pour beaucoup on leur explique
vous n'avez plus d'avenir à gad aux
alentours aller travailler à 50 ou 60 km
ces gens là n'ont pas le permis de
conduire
on va leur dire quoi il faut payer 1500
euros il faut attendre un an
il est très la formule fait bondir les
salariés de la société gad ce matin dit
que les femmes de la plupart de tamda
société gad étaient des illettrés alors
nous on vient vous prouver qu'on est pas
il est très con a permis et qui ont
aussi des administratifs et que toutes
les familles s'ils savent lire et écrire
faire tant d'études pour sortir ça
remonte à sa place quand on connaît pas
les choses dans ferme sa gueule tout
simplement
gad l'histoire d'une petite affaire
familiale passé de 20 salariés dans les
années 50 à plus de 2500 dans les années
2000 lorsque j'étais l'humeur de lampaul
j'avais plus de salariés à
lampaul-guimiliau que d'habitants
[Musique]
fragilisé par la concurrence des pays de
l'est
l'entreprise bretonne ne résiste pas au
changement d'époque
le couperet tombe le 11 octobre 2013
après une année de conflit social
incarné par le délégué syndical olivier
le braz aux côtés du maire de lampaul en
larmes
la décision qui a été prise aujourd'hui
dans l'actionnaire principal cecab
c'est à dire c'est à dire validation pas
laissez moi parler validation du plan de
continuation et autorisation des 883
licenciement
c'était un village qui était
complètement par terre et c'était je
dirais toute une région qui était très
affecté par ce qui venait de se passer
ces salariés qui soit disant ne savent
pas lire vont en tout cas se faire
entendre
moi j'ai senti comme un deuxième coup
près quoi comme un deuxième coup de
bâton à un moment où on n'en avait pas
besoin
ils nous insultent presque des choses
comme il a dit ça
cette époque pour une personne si haut
placé même une personne normale la
manouvre indira passera de de gens
travaillant en usine nous parle comme si
on était des moins que rien ça fait mal
quand même
ça fait mal les gens ne comprenaient pas
pourquoi on avait été ciblé comme ça
alors qu'on était déjà en difficulté
quoi t'as pas su lire tu n'as pas su
écrire et n'a pas le permis
regarde bien ça donc c'est pas de ta
faute
ou peut-être pour eux ils ont tous le
montre bien comme si on montrait un
mauvais bulletin de notre un élève
devant tout le monde
pour moi c'est une grande erreur de
communication il pouvait pas imaginer ce
qu'ils disent qu'ils allaient faire
c'est à dire faire mal à des gens qui
travaillaient dans cette boutique
s'arrêter moins stigmatisant - vexant
moins dur pour nous
si derrière il y apporter la solution
nous l'état on va mettre tant de
millions sur les permis de conduire
nous l'état on va aider les gens qui ont
eu des difficultés à lire et écrire pour
accéder à ce à ce bien commun d'accord
je conçois il a voulu protéger quelque
chose qui voulait mettre en place c'est
à dire le permis à un euro à ce moment
là mais il n'avait pas utilisé ce mot
l'an passé il y a dans cette société une
majorité de femmes
il y en a qui sont pour beaucoup ils les
traits je suis d'ici les deux pieds dans
cette terre qui est très touché par la
crise de l'agroalimentaire et de gad en
particulier le matin j'entends cette
phrase comme un un coût énorme et pour
moi un coup dans le dos la phrase elle
est d'une violence inouïe
à peine lâchée l'expression emballe la
classe politique qui travaillait chez
rothschild a sans doute jamais rencontré
une ouvrière d'agroalimentaire ce
monsieur n'est pas venu voir sur place
ce monsieur alors qu'il est la soi
disant pour aider les salariés les
enfonce et les caricatures quelle
méconnaissance
de la réalité de l'intelligence ouvrière
dans notre pays
il arrive avec un franc-parler moi que
je reçois cinq sur cinq
parce que quand on regarde la réalité de
ce qu'il dit peut-être on peut dire que
c'est mal formulée mais voilà la réalité
des choses on a des salariés qui sont
qui font une tache
depuis longtemps qui sont salariés
depuis longtemps mais qui probablement
n'ont pas la capacité à l'heure actuelle
s'ils ne sont pas formés s'ils ne sont
pas accompagnés à faire autre chose ça
peut être perçu comme caricatural et ça
l'est en partie mais de dire il faut
qu'on change les choses comme moi je le
perçois comme ça vous pouvez dire quand
vous êtes politique il ya trop
d'illettrisme en france ça existe c'est
vrai c'est une réalité faut la prendre
en compte folle à dire folle à décrire
mais il faut la décrire avec chaleur
romaine pour la décrire en disant je
sais quand vous a pas donné cette chance
là moi politique je dois vous donner
cette chance là c'est autre chose que de
balayer comme ça en dix ans alors il ya
des illettrés ça va nous poser problème
erreur de jeunesse si je peux dire un
vieux de la vieille en politique
n'aurait pas parlé comme ça il aurait
dit dans cette entreprise que j'ai
visités avec des personnes qui sont
attachés à leur travail qui le font avec
un grand professionnalisme
mais il ya un certain nombre d'acquis
pour qu'il faudrait une formation
complémentaire de ceux ci cela mais le
mot il est trés ça donnait le sentiment
qu'il traitait une entreprise illettrés
et ça lui revient dans la gueule
première petite phrase et première
conséquence pour le tout jeune ministre
de l'économie pour qui la journée
s'annonce difficile
moi j'appelle emmanuel macron et je lui
ai expliqué que seuls l'excusent public
pourra réparer la déchirure que ces gens
ont forcément ressenti et il avait l'air
surpris par cette demande d' excuses
l'après midi même
ils se retrouvent dans l'arène
démocratique face à des députés prêts à
lui faire payer son parler vrai la
parole est à madame laure de la raudière
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre ce matin à la radio
votre ministre de l'économie a traité
les salariés des entreprises gardent
d'illettrés c'est inadmissible quel
mépris
après le scandale descendants voici
maintenant celui des illettrés
condamnerez vous ces propos c'est sans
pitié l'assemblée nationale il a jamais
pénétré dans l'hémicycle
il doit être tout surpris que les
députés en font une affaire adobe mais
c'est comme ça les salariés de gad
comme tous les français méritent votre
respect mérite le respect tous les
membres du gouvernement on se rend pas
bien compte à la télévision à quel point
c'est un moment fort et qui avait il est
compliqué de parler à l'assemblée avec
l'émotion mais aussi avec le bruit et il
sent qu'il faut que tout de suite qu'il
apaise n'est pas venu pour faire du
combat sur des petites phrases
il est venu pour apporter une vraie
transformation d'amélioration
je crois la société française donc la
parole est à mme à monsieur emmanuel
macron ministre de l'économie de
l'industrie et du numérique
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues on
écoute la réponse merci de me frire
l'occasion de répondre pour exprimer
devant la représentation nationale de
regrets le premier regret c'est pour les
propos que j'ai tenus ce matin
si j'ai blessé et parce que j'ai blessé
des salariés et c'est inacceptable
s'annule pas ce que je voulais faire
si vous écoutez ce que j'ai pu dire ce
matin madame je prenais cet exemple
précisément c'est que ces salariés n'ont
pas eu la formation et la formation
continue qui était en droit d'attendre
et donc mon premier regret mes excuses
les plus plates elles vont à l'égard des
salariés que j'ai pu blesser que j'ai
blessé à travers ses propos et je ne
m'en excuserai jamais assez merci
monsieur ses premières excuses emmanuel
macron les faits à paris sous les ors de
la république
il ya des choses qui marchent pas il
faut les dénoncer on fait parfois
maladroitement
je les fais très maladroitement cette
semaine je m'en suis excusé auprès des
gens que j'ai blessé mais ce qui compte
avant tout c'est de régler les problèmes
parce qu'ils sont là les problèmes mais
il faudra attendre quatre mois pour
qu'il se décide à aller en bretagne
affronter les personnes qui l'a vexé il
a attendu trop longtemps je pense que
c'est ça qui est ça qui a été le plus
douloureux quelque part emmanuel macron
accepte finalement une rencontre avec
une centaine d'anciens salariés
mais à huit clos a été très clair il a
dit je ne vois pas de journaliste je
n'sais personnes que moi sur le principe
moi ça me dérangeait pas parce que ce
qui m'apportait ci qui viennent les yeux
dans les yeux
voir ces salariés qui s'excuse devant
eux et qu'ils puissent y avoir un
échange derrière l'ambiance était quand
même très tendue et l'atmosphère était
plus que lourdes
il rentre dans la salle il traverse la
foule à ce moment-là s'étend du saas
ifsa eu mais c'est respectueux pas d'
insulte il a dit qu'il s'excusait tu
m'excuser pour les propos que que j'ai
prononcé la salle s'apaise et ensuite il
prend le temps d'aller voir le maximum
de gens pour échanger avec eux voilà
comment ça s'est passé
les premières minutes et les dernières
sont plus les mêmes quoi gens non
une demi heure plus tard et des excuses
droit dans les yeux avec des salariés
emmanuel macron se voit remettre un
paquet de pâtes en alphabet un clin
d'oeil pour redescendre sur terre appris
de cet échange beaucoup de choses que je
cadrais pour moi
est-ce que c'est fait c'est la règle du
jeu outré quand je dis que c'est un
climat est un crime
vous êtes un très bon moment j'ai vu des
très bonnes j'ai vu des très belles
personnes c'était très émouvant
ils sont très fiers ce qu'ils sont et je
suis très fier d'eux donc on continuera
on a tous été dans cette salle à se dire
il a osé venir et il est à l'écouté de
nos problèmes
j'ai entendu beaucoup dire c'était
courageux l'enjeu regrette c'était
normal il a pu rencontrer des gens sans
avoir l'angle de la caméra qui le
favorise et ça je pense que il a
forcément été enrichi par ce contact là
et ça c'est ce qu'il faut faire
emmanuel macron va au contact et arrive
à force de dialogue a retourné une salle
hostile à son égard
cet épilogue dans le sourire l'at-il
conforté dans son usage du parler cash
malgré ses excuses il ne semble pas
avoir retenu la leçon
ceux qui pensaient qu'il changerait de
méthode en sont pour leurs frais il va
récidiver au point de le soupçonner de
provocation
[Musique]
comme lorsqu'il croise quelques années
plus tard en tant que président de la
république
un jeune sans emploi lors des journées
du patrimoine à l'elysée
vous êtes inscrits à pôle emploi du goût
et de ciudad de motivation sauf dans
l'hôtellerie qui a fait la restauration
dans le bâtiment il n'y a pas un endroit
où je me dise pas qu'il cherche des gens
beaux hôtels cafés restaurants
je traverse la rue s'en trouvent ils
veulent simplement des gens qui sont
prêts à travailler avec les contraintes
du métier
je pense que beaucoup de français se
disent oui tout ça c'est calculé non il
ya des moments ça sort comme ça et il
faut ensuite le gérer quoi ça fait
partie du bloc d expression qui lui
reviennent dans la figure et qui peuvent
faire dire de lui bon ben c'est arrogant
c'est méprisant ses hôtes un ceux qui
réussissent tant mieux les autres pas
qu'ils se démerdent quoi je viens d'une
culture je pense que c'est la même
culture qui aimait le maquereau travail
on l'attend pas on va le chercher
et quelque part il le prend en main et
lui dit vas-y tu vas y arriver tu bats
toi tu vas tu vas y arriver et c'est
perçu comme de l'arrogance que cette
phrase elle est plutôt bienveillants à
l'égard de ce jeune homme bienveillant
pour les visiteurs qui n'auraient pas
réussi à le croiser reste sa photo sur
papier glacé
emmanuel macron c'est quelqu'un qui n'a
pas fait d'élections locales
on a tous connu ça quand on est élu
local vous devez vous devez apprendre à
leur parler à ces personnes qu'est-ce
que j'ai fait un mitterrand
je vous comprends je nomme je vous
comprends hélas un conseiller prenez
note
écrivez moi je vous aiderai voilà
puisqu'il ya du travail
bien sûr que c'est difficile pour celui
qui est en grande difficulté d'entendre
batwa plus mis au fond qu'est ce qu'on
attend d'un chef d'état c'est qu'ils
nous montrent un chemin qui nous emmène
vers quelque chose de meilleur
sa radicalité emmanuel macron l'assument
et va jusqu'à la mettre en scène comme
dans cette vidéo filmée et mise en ligne
par l'elysée la police est regardé mes
impôts notamment des minima sociaux
les gens ils sont tous impôts on entend
encore les ondines espoirs f pour ceux
qui tombent beau y reste pauvre
on va voir un truc il à nogent son
ensemble il est quelqu'un qui pense
qu'il a raison
le matin le midi le soir etc ayant
raison ils peuvent se permettre beaucoup
de choses qu'ils n'utilisent pas cette
expression le pognon et qu'on dépense 1
po lyon d'un mois je pense qu'un
président il doit parler comme et comme
il est donc d'utiliser des expressions
familières
moi ça me choque pas emmanuel macron est
un enfant du parler cash
ils considèrent non pas que c'est à moi
mais que c'est un plus et puis il ya une
philosophie macro nien c'est la
philosophie des premiers de cordée
celeron considère que l'action politique
est fait avant tout pour les premiers de
cordée qui vont montrer la voie à tous
ceux qui sont derrière et c'est une
conception extrêmement élitiste de la
société sa vision du monde et la société
à laquelle ils aspirent
emmanuel macron en donne un aperçu très
clair ce jour de juillet 2010 est devant
de jeunes créateurs de start-up réunis à
paris après les illettrés les gens qui
ne sont rien une gare c'est un lieu
qu'on croise
les gens qui réussissent et les gens qui
ne sont rien parce que c'est un lieu où
on passe comment peut-on dire ça des
gens qui ne seront rien alors là c'est
très fort on est content c'est un mépris
mais n'ont en effet la lah extrêmement
extrêmement impressionnant c'est une
phrase que vous pouvez pas avaler c'est
brest qui vous étouffe c'est une phrase
qui vous coupe le souffle
ce qui me frappe là dedans c'est qu'il a
une opposition entre le faire et fayer
et lettres ceux qui réussissent sont
ceux qui sont dans le changement dans la
transformation dans la création et ceux
qui ne sont rien c'est des gens qui sont
dans la permanence de leur état un
change à bhl ce qui vous rassemble ce
qui nous rassemble ici aujourd'hui c'est
cet esprit entrepreunarial tous les
accidents de langage de ce type là qui
sont assez proches de la puce ils ont
comme propriété d'être toujours sur le
même registre
donc ça révèle d'autant plus de force
l'espèce de cohérence intérieur d'un
imaginaire social
c'est quelque chose qui renvoie à une
idéologie véritablement politique
presque deux heures de la défense de
l'inégalité comme une donnée naturelle
emmanuel macron c'est l'archétype d'une
tête bien formés dans le moule de
l'élite française
un parcours de gagnant conscient de sa
position c'est un enfant issu choisi
médical et ses cafés les meilleures
écoles est passée par l'ena les grands
corps
vous voyez est bon l'inspection des
finances on est dans une forme de
noblesse d'état faut faire attention ça
peut abîmer sa peu abîmée on a besoin
des bons élèves n'en a besoin aussi de
savoir pourquoi
d'autres ne peuvent pas réussir on peut
être brion on peut être cultivé et ne
pas avoir de pâtes humaines suffisantes
pour sentir que l'autre peut être
dévalorisé peuvent être humilié dans ces
milieux
il peut y avoir un mépris ans il ya pas
de mépris au moins d'une distance
sociale et culturelle à 10,1 avec les
gens dont on parle
entre ces deux mondes celui de la haute
sphère de l'élite des manuels macron et
celui du peuple
l'incompréhension mutuelle grandi nourri
par des petites phrases et des écarts de
langage ça stigmatise et les gens
n'aiment pas être stigmatisés n'aime pas
être remontée du doigt au nom de quoi le
président quelle que soit l'honneur de
sa fonction aurait-il le droit de parler
sur ce ton de nous à présent la
république qui a une vocation à unis où
un candidat à la présidence qu'une
vocation à réunir
il faut qu'ils positifs ceux qui sont en
bas comptent une image de très négatives
qui sont dans une situation de défiance
il faut qu'ils les portent qu'il l'ait
soulève il faut pas espérer de manière
naïve et très technocratique que c'est
le haut qui emportera le bab et ça se
passe pas comme ça la parole publique
suppose de la retenue du choix des mots
en effet les mots sont peuvent être
blessants un mois est une arme quelque
part pas forcément une arme létale mais
une arme politique
c'est tous ces petites phrases des
mondes quand même que ce qu'il avait dit
avec beaucoup de maladresses en tout cas
ce que je pensais au début montre comme
un peu un peu de dédain par rapport à
une certaine population
attention à ce nouveau langage voyez ça
vous permet d'exister dans un premier
temps puis après ça vous plombe parce
que depuis qu'il est au pouvoir celle là
plombé
ça n'a pas servi salle a plombé la
meilleure que ça se travaille et on met
un peu dans les minima sociaux
ils sont impôts il y en a qui sont pour
beaucoup
ils les traits qui a certainement ce
cette volonté de parler cash qui vous
fait dire mais d'énormes bêtises un démo
mais c'est mieux dit que sarkozy mais
c'est d'une violence effrayante et ça va
créer des réflexes extrêmement violent
les gilets jaunes vous voyez il ya un
peu de ça ils se sont nourris de ces
petites phrases et ça fait partie de ces
petits épisodes qui alimente la colère
et malheureusement aussi parfois l'air
[Musique]
oh
avec le mouvement des gilet jaune fin
2018 emmanuel macron a connu comme
président l'un des plus violents
mouvements de contestation du pouvoir en
place dans les manifestations on a bien
vu les pancartes les inscriptions sur
les gels s est jusqu à d'ailleurs alors
ça si l'on léger des jaunes enfin
certains en tout cas on franchit ligne
qui n'était pas acceptable c'est
d'attiser la haine à son égard dans
certaines manifestations on pendait
macron g
là c'est trop à angoulême le quotidien
régional rapporte hier ce simulacre
d'exécution des manuels macron et cette
haine l'un reprenait à la fois les mots
et dans le langage et puis le parcours
de manière macro rothschild l'ena voir
sa jeunesse et c'est quoi il ya une
perception qu'une élite gagne
mondialisée gagne de plus en plus
d'argent et françois de mieux en mieux
et puis une autre qui travaille qui
travaillent dur mais qui arrive pas et
ensuite il ya eu une étincelle
c'est l'augmentation des taxes sur
l'essence qui fait qu'à un moment on en
a ras-le-bol et peut-être qu'à ce moment
là emmanuel macron peu incarne ceux qui
réussissent finalement et qu'il peut
avoir donné le sentiment de ne pas
incarner ceux qui galèrent qui travaille
pour quand vous avez pu rien à perdre ce
genre de phrase ça sert pas apaisé bien
au contraire
ça alimente un petit peu ce feu de la
haine quoi ce feu de la colère enfin moi
sur le conflit gelé vu dans les yeux des
salariés ce feu de la haine ce feu de la
colère pour des gens qui étaient
extrêmement pacifiste extrêmement doux
et qui n'avait plus rien à perdre pour
leur enlever tout et quand en plus au
plus haut au sommet de l'état les gens
qui ont le pouvoir contrairement à ce
qu'on dit on se permet de sortir ce
genre de phrases ses geôles enfin c'est
extrêmement violent
emmanuel macron lui at-il aujourd'hui
perçu les limites de son franc parler il
ya des phrases que je regrette
il ya des phrases qui ont été totalement
sortis de leur contexte c'est une
réalité elles se sont agrégés mais je
crois que j'ai compris beaucoup de
choses de la vie du pays
[Musique]
de ce que d impatience qu'on exprime
avec sincérité croit ton peuvent être
mal comprise et même si on sent que
c'est une injustice quand c'est mal
compris et que ça blesse c'est une
erreur
pour les anciens gad le temps a passé
mais l'étiquette reste il est très grave
car c'est lié maintenant quand on me dit
ah oui c'est vrai tn et les traitons je
souris m'enfin ça fait un peu mal quand
même quoi
joël cren a ouvert son restaurant et
emploie aujourd'hui 3 personnes vous
plaît olivier le braz et agents de
sécurité à l'aéroport de brest et siège
au conseil régional de bretagne depuis
l'épisode des illettrés il s'est donné
pour objectif d'aller porter la parole
ouvrière à l'assemblée l'ancien ministre
est lui devenu président de la
république
depuis le mouvement des gilet jaune et
son pics d'impopularité
emmanuel macron n'a pas vraiment changé
sa méthode peut-être at-il déjà les yeux
tournés vers la prochaine élection
présidentielle tout comme françois
hollande jamais loin des médias
tous deux ont payé cher leurs petites
phrases et espère peut-être renouer avec
le peuple
il leur faudra apprendre à tenir leur
langue
[Musique]